-♪♪ Emotional Interview ♪♪
-Now, here's how it works.
We're going to have a normal
conversation with each other,
except every so often, we're
gonna hear this ding sound.
[ Ding! ]
And when we hear that,
we'll be given an emotion
or situation that we have
to act out as we keep talking.
-Okay.
-Sounds good?
-Yeah.
-Here we go.
All right, ready?
[ Ding! ]
All right, summer's almost here.
-Yeah.
-And --
-I love summer, man.
-Oh, do you rem--
-I love it.
-I used to go to the old --
old Stovehill.
-Yeah?
-Yeah.
-Did you?
-And climb up it and roll down.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, yeah.
-Yeah, man.
-I remember that.
I love rolling down.
I love rolling down, too.
-You do?
-Yeah, I do.
-Oh, I love --
-Rolling down is, like,
one of the best things
you can do with your time.
-Oh, I love that!
My grandfather
always used to sing...
♪♪ Rollin' down ♪♪
-Yeah.
-My grandpa
had a very high voice.
-Yeah.
[ Ding! ]
My grandfather
was Stevie Wonder,
but whatever.
What do I know?
I don't even...
[ Laughter ]
I mean --
Eh, that's pretty cool, I guess.
I don't know.
I used to go
to concerts all the time.
-I am Stevie Wonder.
-You are?
[ Ding! ]
-Yeah, I am.
-That's interesting because --
Let's just not do this, okay?
-Could you just --
Why are you --
-It's just --
No, it's good.
-Keep your voice down.
-I will.
[ Chuckles nervously ]
I am keeping it down.
Keeping it down right now, okay?
You're the one who said it.
So why don't you
go start the car,
and then,
I'll meet you out there.
I'll get the check.
-I want a divorce.
I want a divorce.
-You want a divorce.
[ Ding! ]
You'll get one, all right.
You'll get one.
Because you know what?
I think that you need a divorce.
-You should get divorced.
[ Laughter ]
You should get divorced.
-No, you need a divorce.
-You need it more than I do.
[ Light laughter ]
-No, I mean,
I really feel like you --
-No. I think you should.
[ Laughter ]
-No.
-I really do.
-I-I-I think that you --
It's not -- Look at you.
You know?
-I think you're the --
Look at me?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Look, I feel like
you need a divorce.
[ Laughter ]
[ Ding! ]
Because if you do that --
-I don't know.
Hey! I love your tie.
-I went to the baseball game --
-I also really hate your face.
[ Laughter ]
-Wait. I went to
a baseball game once --
-I don't know why
your hair is so high --
-He was swinging the bat,
I go,
"Why would he keep
swinging the bat?"
-What's that?
-"Oh, that's baseball."
-What is that?
-What --
What is that?
-Football I like, too.
[ Ding! ]
-You look so good.
-How dare you.
[ Laughter ]
-No. I', saying --
-How dare you say
that to me on my show?
-I'm saying
you look really well.
-Oh, you come over to --
You said --
-You look good and rested.
You look good and happy.
-We're bleeping it out.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm telling you
something very --
-What are you saying?
-That you are --
-Beep!
[ Laughter ]
[ Ding! ]
I'm beeping.
Beep, beep, beep, beep.
'Cause I'm a truck driver!
[ Laughter ]
Beep, beep --
I got the delivery over here!
[ Laughter ]
Beep, beep, beep, beep.
-No.
-Hold on a second.
-Click. Click.
I can't --
-Want me to drive that truck?
[ Laughter ]
When all I do
is drive all day long,
giving everybody their presents
and their gifts
that they ordered on Amazon
and UPS...for my kids!
[ Laughter ]
I work so hard...
-No, I can't.
I can't.
-...to make sure that they
don't have to sleep
in the back of the truck.
[ Laughter ]
-You got the job, man!
-I got it?
-You got the job!
-Yes, I got the job!
That's what I wanted.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That was an emotional interview
with Sarah Paulson!